in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast welcome to the
co-host of this month we have Edric
slash Edie - back in the house yes sir
yeah well we're gonna talk about a
subject today that I know that a lot of
us want I feel like I do have to cover
this you know it's it's it's hard for me
to cover subjects like this because it's
so fresh in you right yeah and I want to
be able to kind of sit and think about
something like this before I go ahead
and start popping off so when I first
started doing YouTube I remember
whenever whenever something was like of
social injustice and that was the the
you know the type of wave that I was put
alright right there's some [ __ ] that
kind of motivates me that gets me going
right I would just say my opinion on the
stuff without really kind of sitting and
having the time to think about it off
the cuff right I was a cop yeah nothing
was really set in stone but I think now
because a lot of media facets are like
that it's more about getting first
before getting the information right
yeah they don't ever want to sit on
ideas and thoughts so this has been
going on for like the past couple of
days and I don't know when this episode
is gonna release most likely next week
early June but we are gonna talk about
it's George Floyd right so recently if
you guys don't know this which everybody
does because this is like the biggest
thing of 22 first of all 20 20s and
already tony has been [ __ ] horrible
yeah because so you know so George Floyd
he was in the way that I'm gonna put it
was [ __ ] murdered by say four cops
right whatever three by standards at one
cop that put a knee on his neck because
they said that he was resisting arrest
and so what happened in this situation
you'll see in the video clip the cop had
a knee with his weight on it to the back
of his [ __ ] neck cutting off his
breathing and during this whole time and
so the reason why the cops were called
over because there was a convenience
store or a market of some sort that said
that he had a bounced check or some
forged money used right which is a
non-violent [ __ ] crime oh my god the
worst [ __ ] crime ever afford a
[ __ ] criminal exactly enough to where
you [ __ ] put your knee to the back of
his [ __ ] neck
right and so you know he throwing this
clip it's kind of hard to watch because
he's saying he can't breathe it [ __ ]
hurts and then I even read that or never
somebody can correct me if I'm wrong I
have to look at the footage again but
his last words was him calling out for
his mom and then he passes away which is
one of the hardest things I've ever seen
and this is only recently after the aman
armory case right where that young man
was chased down and hunted like a
[ __ ] wild animal and there was
another case - with a with a with a
woman i didn't even get to read that
[ __ ] because i'm still reading about a
Matar barry i'm still reading about
george floyd you know yeah and people
want us to i don't know what i can
really say about this [ __ ] right except
for the fact that how [ __ ] terrible
it is and so since this stuff has been
going on
obviously there's protests and obviously
there's riots and there's a lot of bad
things that are happening because of
this and just having to sit and think on
it it's kind of weird how when these
things happen you really get to see
people's true colors come out yeah right
right it's it's very evident about how a
lot of people who see this type of [ __ ]
the first thing that they do they don't
say why is this happening to this man
this is something terrible that happened
that's happening in this country the
first thing they ask when they see a
black man dive at a cops hands they go
what did he do right that's the question
what did he do yeah and that's the part
that bothers me a lot right we have a
lot of comparisons and you know right
now in Minnesota there was a huge riot
which by the way there's this is not
funny it's very funny to me though not
because of the situation but there's
this video clip of this lady in a
wheelchair did you see that she hadn't
hi didn't so yo so this is lady in a
wheelchair and she's trying to stop the
rioting in the looting she decides to
try to stop the looting at the target so
she's in the wheelchair right and then
she stopped and it's funny cuz you see
in the footage there's this white girl
that's going in yeah she didn't stop her
but there was a black woman trying to go
in and she tries to stop her instead
yeah and so she's like yo get the [ __ ]
off me yeah and then she whips out a
knife and she tries to stab the lady
she was so I thought she was a grandma
she's 30 years old people did I age well
I'll do my this [ __ ] was she's 30 years
old and she tries to stand this lady and
so they're like yo this [ __ ]
trying to stab somebody and so somebody
gets a fire hydrant and just blasts the
face she looks ridiculous
I'm not even lying she looks like Chris
Farley oh my she looks like [ __ ]
Chris Farley that wheelchair evil and
then you should see this clip after yeah
and they go in this person recorded like
what happened she goes I was peacefully
protesting and these people started
punching me and they were attacking me
for no reason
it's like listening here you dumb [ __ ]
yeah there is a culture and people that
are upset right they're rioting and you
in a [ __ ] wheelchair with your 450
pound ass is trying to stop a bunch of
people from riding after the justice
happened yeah I think you're [ __ ]
your perspective is a little [ __ ] right
now
yeah yeah right and I think like the
stuff that I'm reading right now that
listen I understand let me go riding and
looting isn't making anything better
right it's making the situation worse
and it makes you know the black people
you know black culture and black
Americans look bad right well let me
just kind of give you a perspective and
a flip on this right I understand that
but I also get the other side more than
that side and the reason why is this
okay the question that people should ask
is number one what do you want from them
mm-hmm what should they do right I'm
talking about black Americans in this in
in in the United States they protest
peacefully they get maced they get Kier
bombed right they follow these rules
where they say don't resist right just
go along nothing will happen to you a
man gets his next stepped on he loses
his life and he gets choked out to death
right rest in peace George Floyd rest in
peace Eric garner for selling cigarettes
outside of a store and he lost his
[ __ ] life okay so we abide by these
[ __ ] rules right you are set here to
protect and to serve next step we are
going to protest this which is the
American right that's what we can do
right they get tear gas they get told to
shut the [ __ ] up there's these fake
promises and these promises from
officials saying that we're gonna change
and we're going to do better but until
you show that it doesn't mean anything
it really [ __ ] doesn't yeah and so
people are surprised so why would they
[ __ ] do this well how would you feel
you're put into a corner let me tell you
something when you push people into a
corner you put any animal into a corner
human being or not [ __ ] things
are gonna come out yeah and now you're
wondering
why you got bid it's like listen
protesting didn't work they got tear
bomb and gas and just to put this in
perspective if you remember just not too
long ago because the pandemic was so
hard we saw protests of hordes of white
people screaming an inch away from these
cops faces right they didn't get
tear-gassed they didn't get nothing
happened no signs of violence but you
see the other way around they get
destroyed oh don't forget the white
supremacy you know protesting - yeah
nothing happened there absolutely
nothing yeah and they're literally a
gang yeah it's the oddest thing and so
when you ask that question of hey or
when you say like oh looting and rioting
isn't the way I understand that but then
I also on the other side of what did you
expect what's going to happen yeah you
keep killing these people over and over
and over again and you ask them just
wait in due time be patient well guess
what when when is that time gonna come
right how long do you expect these
people to constantly be patient to
constantly wait because a generation
before that and a generation before that
those same people told them just wait be
patient be patient be patient be patient
people get [ __ ] tired and now you see
these riots happen and then you condemn
them for that well guess what I don't
think that is right and I agree that
looting and rioting isn't going to help
but when people are hurt when their
people are being killed what did you
expect
right and so it's easy to kind of
understand where that anger is stemming
from right it was the same thing with
the LA riots right but once it gets to
the looting and rioting stage there are
the Free Riders right yeah freeloaders
who come in and think oh [ __ ]
you know people are rioting and looting
free [ __ ] right but that's it's kind of
distracting from what the topic at hand
is actually about why that anger blew
over right yeah it's just like you know
you walking every day and just somebody
kicking you in the ass for no apparent
reason they do it every single day you
know at a certain point you might punch
that person
Oh like that enough is enough right III
just minding my own business you kick
you keep kicking me every single day
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you and then
you get upset because you got a negative
reaction from it and what I really want
to ask and sometimes two men I keep
reading this [ __ ] where it's it's my
opinion is [ __ ] they go it's it's
not the the their thing is it's not as
bad as it used to be that doesn't really
speak for much right and there are
people out there that wants to deny the
the the preferable treatment that white
people get in this country right if I
were to put it to you like this maybe
maybe this might help you understand
right I'm just gonna give you a scenario
you are driving in your car right you
are a white male you're driving in a
very affluent rich [ __ ] neighborhood
right you're just driving minding your
business everything is cool right and as
you're driving you see a cop sign and go
behind you right that cop is telling you
to pull over well guess what in this
world in this scenario I'm gonna give
you a button right and that button says
that you have an option when you get
pulled over by this cop you hit that
button and you could change your
ethnicity to a black man would you do it
would you do it be real be a [ __ ]
honest with yourself for a second would
you [ __ ] do it yes or no if that
answer is no you know why because you
understand that you being a white person
being pulled over by cop is an
advantageous thing to have right and
conversely the other way around if you
are a black male in this country and you
also were in that same situation you are
in a regular car driving down this
affluent neighborhood you had a button
and it says hey in this moment this cop
pulls you over you can be a white man I
guarantee you oppressor - because you
understand most likely will get less
[ __ ] thrown on you and you just might
not get your ass beat yeah so if your
answer that question is you know what if
I was a white dude and a cop pulled me
over I probably want to stay white
instead of a black male then you that
means you actually do understand that
you do have a little bit of this thing
called white [ __ ] privilege and it's
a very simple concept to understand and
it's annoying when I guess sometimes
it's not acknowledged like it's just a
fable or it's a myth you know right
right I mean honestly the thing that
bothers me the most is the different
type of narratives that come up in you
know tragedy
like this and a lot of the times you
know it's people are trying to come
across not as racist with with some of
the comments that they make about oh the
police was just doing their job
this person was a criminal right but III
don't understand how you can make some
of these comments and and have some of
these I guess ideas and thoughts and not
realize that that's exactly what a
racist would see like it's it's not
rocket science
yeah and and maybe it's just a lack of
self-awareness or maybe they're just you
know so deep into that mindset that
they're just completely oblivious
they're just disconnected from what
racism looks like yeah right what racism
what a racist talks like you know how
racist thinks and it's it's like really
really disheartening to pretty much have
people devalue these people's lives
Yeah right kind of talk about it like so
matter-of-factly like well yeah of
course that happened right look at what
they did look at who they are
Ricky forged a check yeah exactly man
all right and and I just I don't get it
man i I don't understand how if you have
any decency as a human being you can't
just look at it first and foremost a
person has lost their life yeah let's
start there let's let with the Cuban
part right let's let that be the
starting point and from there and look
it's not to discredit like the cops who
actually do do their jobs right yeah and
so it is important about if they
committed a serious crime right if
they're if they're trying to kill
somebody right and and the cops have to
take them down and it was protocol I'm
not gonna go as far as saying that was
the right
thing to do but it might be a little bit
more understandable yeah they were
threatening other people's lives or
worse already did you know take a life
somebody right and then so they have to
put that person down but when it comes
to nonviolent crimes petty crimes really
why does that even matter right why does
that become the focus like oh yeah this
person committed a crime regardless
there's different levels of crimes yeah
and there's different levels of
punishment as a result of it right yeah
and unfortunately in this country time
and time again black people just get the
[ __ ] end of the stick
yeah right not not only in getting
profiled but getting worse sentences
right and and and and the absolute worst
losing their life yeah right
and and I just these people man here in
this country speak from such a stance of
like almost just like a sense of
entitlement ya know it's almost like
they know best yeah well don't you know
yeah it's just don't you know type of
attitude yeah it's like eat you and it's
it's hard to listen to sometimes man and
I I think that I read a comment I you
know I block this person to because they
were making a comparison of like it's a
dumb comparison to say this right and
they were saying like oh why are you so
passionate about stuff it's like do you
think you should speak on stuff like
that it's not even your culture I was
like well hold on a second let me let me
just kind of put this in perspective and
this might not apply to you but this
applies to me for sure right I always
talk about how I grew up the people that
I've been around the way that I speak
now I think the hard part and I'm not
I'm not speaking as a black black black
male yeah I think there's an Asian
American man yeah a person of color too
just on a different spectrum
it's annoying for even me when I see
this right hip hop culture jazz pop
culture all this other stuff yeah you
can see where this source comes from
right and everything that's hip and cool
actually comes from a lot of black
culture that a lot of people imitate
right right they take they take they
take here's how the problem is and this
is where I see it this is how I see it
right
how can you sit there every day
sometimes these people's brands their
music everything that they do there'll
image how they speak how they talk all
comes with this black culture they still
and they take that [ __ ] and they're cool
with it
but the moment that you have to speak up
on stuff that's affecting that culture
you go hey I'm not black it's not my
business all right
how [ __ ] terrible is that I mean
culture appropriation yeah it's like you
take and take and take but when it's
time for you to give back to a culture
that has given you so much you're just
like it's none of my business all right
so now I so that's why if you hear
people say like you hear this anger and
also this annoyance with people where
they say like well you are you an ally
watch I'm not really big on that term
but I guess I'm just gonna use it in
this sense they go are you an ally or
not and I think that comes from a lot of
frustration of us like yo you [ __ ]
steal from black culture all the time
and we're cool with it right but now
we're getting [ __ ] over and you see
that [ __ ] and you're okay with it and
you just want to be quiet about it
because you're not black yeah but you've
benefited so much from this [ __ ] and the
crazy thing is that you have to
understand like a lot of this like cool
stuff that you see in black culture also
stemmed from their oppression they took
their [ __ ] lemons and they may
lemonade out of it and with that
lemonade we didn't have to deal with the
sour lemons we just took the [ __ ]
lemonade right and now we're cool just
drinking that [ __ ] to ourselves all the
[ __ ] time yeah
without lending help when they need it
the most that's why for someone like me
because I grew up in black culture even
the way that I speak the way that I you
know the way that I think the music that
I enjoy stands on a lot from black
American culture so for me it does
affect me right it does hurt when I see
a black male being having a [ __ ] knee
to the back of his neck it sucks when I
see Eric garner for selling cigarettes
on the side of a corner getting choked
out and killed sucks when I see a mod
jogging and he gets murdered it's
terrible for me because if I don't say
stuff like this right which I
technically yeah I don't have to but I
feel like I do need to because I am
somebody who partook in taking the
positives from this culture so when this
culture needs help I got to say
something
mm-hmm you know yeah I mean and and the
the sad thing about it is it situations
like this always almost inevitably
becomes political right if you are
showing
compassion you're getting called a
far-left
lipped hard right yeah and if you're
justifying you know the act of the cops
then you're a nutjob right wing right
it's not about politics about this you
don't it doesn't matter whether you're a
[ __ ] Democrat liberal a Republican
like it's about human compassion you
know it's just about being a human being
yeah I know and you do not at your
political affiliation has no effect on
you being able to show compassion right
problem is though and and we touched
upon this on previous podcast is that
right now in this country man a certain
group of people are empowered you know
and these groups of people let's just
say don't aren't necessarily fighters of
equality yeah yeah they're they're not
exactly people of of justice
you know only justice when it's
convenient for them not not not equal
justice right and it's like why why does
why there's a situation like this have
to be so divisive yeah you know again
why can't we start at the core issue
which is a human being died yeah right
and and let's let's at least have the
conversation from that point on but
people now are just so quick to be like
oh you you know you have a just a lift
heart you know mindset you know you you
have the you know it's it's strange to
think about too because it's like the
fact that you're showing compassion
makes your lip tart yeah you know so odd
right yeah people kind of just they put
their political agenda in this type of
stuff yeah that's true like I I do agree
with you let's start with the human side
right and we're even like I'll even
bring it up like this where yeah man I
got I mean I was so disappointed when
the asian dude was there I was
Asian Kolkata dammit god no you know and
his name was like to tau or tau tow
right here like the most Asian name ever
man I like him I wish his name was like
Keith Keith Powers or some [ __ ] you know
I mean it's like nah man he's white he
just looks Asian but this dude had the
most [ __ ] Asian name ever dude how
toe - yeah and so this [ __ ] I
think this is why I've been trying to
get a cop to come on here right not
because I wanted to attack them I just
want to know what protocol is not so I
can protect myself but I want to know
what it's like to be a cop in those type
of situations not to defend what
happened but what goes on in your head
when you see this stuff happens right or
what would you see was happening in that
situation and I was kind of on Twitter
and I was reading a few things from
other cops and they were saying that
it's protocol that when somebody's doing
their thing like that that you have
somebody to make sure that you're
securing the perimeter Yeah right I
completely understand that the the issue
that I have with that too is that we saw
on the security cam - there's a security
cam footage that was released that
[ __ ]
George Floyd was calm as hell he was
brought up they cuffed him he was
sitting down he grabbed him by his bicep
and his arm he he walked over to him
with the car and then he kind of winced
in pain or some [ __ ] like that then it
kind of goes off camera and the next you
know he's on the floor he wasn't trying
to run he wasn't struggling he was calm
he was detained he had cuffs on him yeah
so having to say that you have to secure
the perimeter when there's four cops
around and there was multiple
eyewitnesses saying that everybody was
calm nobody was screaming there was just
you just heard those people there play
like yo bro do something do something
help him out help them out they weren't
saying they weren't screaming at him
approaching at him in anger they were
pleading yeah and I think the hard part
was watching that Asian dude there was
how I think when I look at him he he was
conflicted he was like I'm a cop these
are my brothers in blue mm-hmm right but
at the same time he knew that somebody
was being hurt right yeah and I knew I
could I could I could I want to say this
on his behalf also it kind of dams him
too at the same time yeah that he knew
something bad was happening Yeah right
but he chose to secure the Primmer not
even look back to see if the guy was
okay right
because if he did and he saw the guy was
suffering and he was dying it would just
confirm how terrible this [ __ ] was yeah
and he just chose to look away and to me
that was worse yeah it's like if you you
could have secured the perimeter you
could have walked backwards saw was
going on and saying okay officer I think
we're good or he didn't have to do that
he'd be like let me take over from here
or some [ __ ] right but having said that
I'm trying to play devil's advocate and
say he was looking for his job maybe he
has a family but on the human level of
things he [ __ ] up right and the thing
is it's you know cop culture is like a
fraternity yeah you know it's a gang
yeah it's a gang yeah and so like if you
become an outsider you're not gonna have
a good time you know yeah they'll make
you feel it yeah yeah so if it's like
you said yeah they're there are
obviously factors that might go into him
having to think really quickly on the
spot yeah like all [ __ ] you know I got I
got a wife and kids you know I can't do
anything that might jeopardize my job or
my career I worked too hard for this or
whatever but yeah there is a flip side
to that is what are you you're a police
officer what are you supposed to do to
serve exactly protect and serve uphold
the law right not not bully people or
watch somebody get bullied and just kind
of uh you know turn the blind eye to it
right so I you know who knows what was
going through his head at the time maybe
he was having those thoughts or maybe he
just didn't have any thoughts he's only
thinking about making sure nobody comes
in you know tries to do something right
whatever the case is it's I think a lot
of the times the fact that they do it so
nonchalantly yeah you know it's like
yeah I'm gonna throw this [ __ ]
guy on the ground you know or I'm gonna
keep my my knee on his neck and just
chill yeah you know I'm gonna just chill
for a few wasn't I wanted to see in that
video of that guy trying to shake him
off yeah wasn't even doing that yeah
yeah how was the hard part of watch and
you know I had a conversation with the
friend of mine and she was saying that
what the [ __ ] was that guy thinking what
was he doing blah blah blah and I was
like I'll tell you exactly what he was
doing he knew that there was cameras on
him yeah he knew that there were people
recording him watching him doing this
terrible deed but what happens is is
that [ __ ] as a cop as a
disgusting cop he got his ego in the way
he goes I'm a cop I'm the person of
authority I'm the one that set the rules
so they're telling me right now as a
recording me hey you're not supposed to
be doing that yeah it's not gonna admit
that while he's being recorded he's
gonna let his ego get in the way and say
just continue to do he goes no I'm down
double down he's gonna double down and
show how right he is that how he is just
as he is law and what he's doing is
what's it what he says and that's how it
goes yeah and that's what was happening
he didn't let go of his knee because he
didn't want to let go of his [ __ ] ego
yeah that's what was happening and look
man there's no way that as a human being
you can do your job as a police officer
without bias absolutely no way yeah it's
it's it's just impossible what you see
yeah you're not a robot right and and
look there are studies done on this you
know it's it's a fact that there are
biases involved right it's just a matter
of what you do how you think and how you
react right within within those spices
that you have but you know as we're
clearly seeing in these situations those
biases our biases IOC's maybe biases I
can't correct you know let's lie bro
he's right
my swass
[Music]
but yeah it's just kind of a getting a
you're seeing the full-blown bias coming
out right and the the travesty is that a
lot of the times you're not going to
jail for this yeah there's no hard point
there maybe they'll lose their job that
maybe that's the worst that'll happen
yeah you just go to an
[ __ ] you know yeah be a cop somewhere
else yeah right they're not they're not
banned from ever becoming another cop
again you know it's just uh maybe
they're local I don't know station right
but you rarely rarely see any jail time
being served in these times of they
would die in jail Oh first yeah they
would probably have to put him in a some
of the pedophiles yeah yeah they would
have to separate that ball sucker so
yeah yeah dude you they would be like in
a tryst group yeah
so look man I what what can we really do
to change the system you know what I
mean
and and that's why things like rioting
happens because that's the same question
people are asking themselves what the
[ __ ] can we do you know we're so mad and
we've done all these things the right
way right you know what [ __ ] this you
know if you guys aren't gonna pay
attention we're gonna force you to pay
attention right and it's unfortunate
that it has to escalate to that level
but like we were just talking about I
completely understand where that anger
stems from and and how it blows over how
it boils over you know that's what
people should really think about that's
why I'm saying like with the riot stuff
like I said I don't think writing is
right yeah but you also have to
understand why this happened yeah it
didn't happen out of nowhere it's
continual it's they just continue to get
murdered yeah they're watching their
brothers and sisters die constantly
right and now it's just it's just racial
division all over against the rights all
[ __ ] over again right people will get
restless if they followed by the rules
they do the right thing and they still
get killed you leave them no [ __ ]
choice right and that's the [ __ ] sad
part about it it's like people won't
recognize that the reason why it got to
this point but they're what they want to
do is point out the bats that that's
happening at the end things just don't
happen like that things happen for a
[ __ ] reason if you don't acknowledge
that then there isn't going to be any
change there is no healing that's going
to happen
yeah cuz the sad part is even with this
right as this whole situation happens
there's a few cops that come out and
they go this was wrong but people need
to see more of that right if you as a
cop you're a cop and you don't even
speak up for this part - you're not
helping anybody out at this point
because you're also agreeing that oh
this band of brotherhood is more
important than kind of letting this
community know that we're also here to
protect and serve you as well yeah it's
and look again that's such a complicated
thing because you don't even have to be
at that station you know you could be in
another state like another state but
they're kind of throw your your brother
under the bus right by speaking out
against it might kind of put a target on
your back exactly the thing is hard it's
like yeah they're [ __ ] either way so
it's like there's something wrong with
the system that really needs to be fixed
they got to fix the type of people that
they hire they have to make these the
requirements to be a cop a little more
stringent they have to think about these
things man psychological assessments
there's so many different things that
have to come into this yeah I do
I'm not a cop I don't know the stret
type of stress that they go through so
this is me talking out of turn about
that stuff but as somebody who's a
civilian that I'm trying to get a cop on
here to speak their mind and be honest
about stuff I'm not trying to attack
them I just want to know I want to
understand the perspective right so
there can be an open conversation but
until you do that there isn't anything
that's going to happen from this yeah I
mean another great example - you know
about the lady who was at the dog park
no okay so there was a lady who was at
the dog park yeah and she had a dog that
wasn't on her on leash yeah that doesn't
look crazy yeah and so this guy is an
avid bird watcher if you research about
this dude apparently he's like you know
like I really graduate or something very
educated yeah you look at this dude he
looks like the most clean-shaven black
dude you ever seen in her life and the
fact that I think he was saying that his
set yeah right and he asked her yes
young Karen hey Karen can you please put
your dog on a leash right and then he
records her calling the cops saying like
well sir if you don't turn off your
phone I'm gonna call the cops and then
as she gets on the phone she starts
faking this voice as if she's being
assaulted she goes there's a man over
here he's a black male and he's scaring
me and he's assaulting you know he's and
it's like oh my [ __ ] god yeah she's
doing everything within her power to
make
sure that this man ends up [ __ ] killed
by the cops and she knows young Karen
knows that's a rapper named young Karen
knows the power that she has as a white
woman being attacked by a black man and
if she calls the cops and does his
crying fake crying voice as if she's
getting assaulted that he's gonna come
and get [ __ ] up as she knew about that
power yeah that right there she's this
woman even recognize her white power who
[ __ ] privilege yeah she try to use it
to get this man hurt and he's she's just
average black dude right and and look
let's let's be clear about one thing too
though is this isn't a situation where
we should be attacking any group of
people right now like white privilege is
real think sure right but at the same
time white people should not be attacked
because something like police violence
is for sure is going on right this is
the act of a specific person on another
person right and the cop happened to be
white and the victim happened to be
black right but then within that there's
that dynamic right there there's a lot
of issues there and a lot of friction
there yeah I do want to preface this too
just because I and I and I think I said
this on the previous podcast where we
talked about this how even me as an
individual I can't blame a whole subset
of people yeah a whole ethnicity right
because of you know whatever 2 percent 3
percent of these really terrible bad
seeds right because I would hate for
that to happen to anybody right like it
you know in high school like I remember
I I told I said this to were the first
time I was ever called the [ __ ] and a
Google's from a black girl well from
that non if it was scarred and I was I
black people are racist and I just kind
of blanketed the whole ethnicity it
would be a terrible situation today
obviously it runs more deep with black
culture you know a white culture in this
country but what I'm saying is that when
we do that it just kind of breeds more
hate right because I think the sad part
is and I'm and I'm reading this too and
I read a lot of angry anger a lot of
like deep hurt on both sides too because
when i when i was reading comments on
twitter you see that asian cup and i saw
a lot of repetitive comments saying well
this is why we can't [ __ ] with asian
people and you guys have to fight your
own battles because your people do this
to black people right but they took that
individual cop and they blanket in all
the beijing people with that
that kind of sucks too right because if
it what it would have really sucked too
in that situation where we seen a lot of
covert attacks and when you see a lot of
these videos is not a lot of white
people doing it yeah it's alright
actually there's a good amount of white
people but there's like a lot of it's
also a lot of black people hurting a lot
of Asian people mm-hmm you know there
was those kids who [ __ ] high kicked
and jumped kissing Asian lady in the
face and they were young black men and
if I if I as Asian man said you know
[ __ ] all black people from that point
yeah I would lose a bit of my humanity
and I don't want that [ __ ] right right I
want to blame those young gentlemen for
what they did and understand that a
majority people in that culture aren't
like that right you know right and so
like I want all of us to be very careful
about how you kind of see your hate
towards a whole group of people versus
kind of you know blame the individuals
and the and the problem may be like the
underlying problems of like white
privilege and power and such yeah yeah
well and here's the thing too
it shouldn't be a hate you know for
anything it like anger sure feeling
demoralized sure sad about it sure but I
think hate is is like a very very strong
and negative thing and and hate
cultivates hate you know what I mean
it's it's it's like it's like a vicious
cycle so I know it's it's hard to say
because it's not a person that I
personally knew right but if I imagine
being like a brother to him right or or
a cousin to him or or just a close
friend to him right and this guy lost
his life I think it would be very easy
to slip into a dark space and hate you
know not only that person but maybe a
group of people right but I don't know
man I feel like in order for us to have
any progress with it you always have to
kind of stay above it you know what I
mean don't don't let yourself get that
get down to that level because then from
that level is when you might do things
that are irrational you know and that
that is more emotionally charged yeah
yeah
like you said sitting to let let it
digest and marinate first before you
take action or you speak on it but again
like a life was lost right it's it's
hard not to have an emotional reaction
to that and and speak and act based on
that it's just like so much stuff being
brought up to like people are bringing
up you know during the riots and you
know the Latasha Harlan situation which
is killed by that Korean store you know
store owner you know and and I remember
when we did the film cook a lot of
people said like well what is your take
on that you you as a Korean man knows
like you know I see that Korean woman if
you're asking me if she should go to
jail she should have gone to jail 100%
she should have went to jail she killed
a little girl for no reason yeah like
it's hard for me to say that sometimes
too because sometimes I picture my mom
yeah you know right
but that woman was [ __ ] insane she
shot a little girl yeah for [ __ ] what
for what
you know she because she thought she was
stealing or some juice or some [ __ ] and
then you [ __ ] shot that girl well I
think I think what had happened now my
memory is a little fuzzy on it but I
think the girl punched her yeah and then
she grabbed a gun so like we don't know
apparently the the altercation started
from basically the shop owner accusing
the girl of stealing something and I
don't know what prompted the you know
the physical aspect of it but yeah again
it wasn't necessary to escalate it to
that exactly like but that's that's the
main takeaway yes like it didn't who the
[ __ ] cares you know yeah and I want to
say that too because you know maybe some
Asian people might be upset with me I
said what was that with your mom my
mom's not that dumb people have stolen
from my mom before too and she goes if
it was a young person my mom would just
let them go because there's a young
person but the next time they come and
i'ma talk to them yeah yeah person right
like just to escalate it to that point
my mom's smarter than that yeah she was
she would never do that [ __ ] and she
never had to there were times when
people swung at my mom yeah and my mom
just had to take it she called the cops
and the cops handled it
you know what I mean and yeah and so
when I was asked that question and they
were like do you think she should have
gone to jail I was like a hundred
percent she murdered a little everything
she got like ten months of house arrest
yeah it wasn't
it wasn't fair yeah it wasn't fair yeah
like I'm not choosing a race ID at that
point I'm going down to the human side
yeah woman she's Korean cool she's a
shop owner cool she's a business woman
she came in immigrated to this country
she struggled a lot that's cool she's
probably seen a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's happened to her same with my mom
yeah I never killed anybody exactly you
know there's always that caveat right
yeah is that there's plenty of other
people who've been in similar situations
that did not do that
yeah who did not feel the need to take a
life right so yeah in that sense it was
definitely wrong and and the punishment
was way too light yeah for what she did
and that happened and then the Rodney
King beating happen exactly and that was
the tipping point it was just game what
and this is what it is yeah it's starts
with Eric Gardner mm-hmm right it starts
with I'm forgetting this young man's
name it was the guy who was killed by um
Trayvon Trayvon Martin it was Trayvon
Martin and now it's George Floyd it was
the young lady forgive me after I think
I name is Brianna Taylor or something I
forgot her name but I haven't even
looked into this case right now but the
photo me is pretty [ __ ] up yeah it's
her and then I'm on our burry mm-hmm how
this is too frequent it's happening too
much right and I want to see is you know
just to hear her out the other somebody
else's point they go well you know a lot
of white people are killed by cops too
cool show me those videos show me the
video where a white person bounces a
check and the cop has his [ __ ] knee
on the back of his neck for [ __ ] five
minutes and chokes him out
show me the [ __ ] video where somebody
is selling the cigarettes Yeah right and
I choke this dude out until he dies yeah
show me those videos and then maybe I'll
see some validity in your statement
right but when I keep seeing is the
opposite right I'm seeing the crazy
white guy walking around swinging a
[ __ ] knife and a cop chasing and cops
chasing this guy throughout the
neighborhood for [ __ ] hours saying
it's not worth it put the [ __ ] knife
down put the knife down running away
from his he's charging at them with a
knife yeah trying to commit suicide
begging the cops to basically shoot him
and
even [ __ ] do it because they see that
his life is worth it right but they see
your guys selling cigarettes in a corner
you choke him out mm-hmm you see a guy
bouncing a check not even resisting
arrest from the footage as we've seen
now they won't even release the body cam
footage yeah and you see the guy getting
choked out and losing his [ __ ] life
so show me that show me that and then
maybe I'll see Oh all cops are a piece
of [ __ ] to everybody you know cops are
just [ __ ] pigs to everybody yeah I
guess well and that's the thing too
within within cops in general right we
can't we can't generalize here there are
a lot of good cops out there their
community and do their job with honor
and integrity right but just like any
group of people there's always the bad
seats you know and unfortunately if
those bad seeds are the ones who are the
ones doing this type of [ __ ] yeah and
like the real question is then right
from that point on how what you kind of
touched on earlier is how can we
evaluate like this like you Val's that
these cops have to go through right now
what can we do to make sure that they're
mentally fit for the job you know
because I I'm pretty sure psych evals
are things that they have to go through
it's a tough job yeah yeah before going
before becoming a cop right well I
remember in a in Sosh
I was a social major we would learn
about how a lot of domestic violence is
is pretty prevalent within like cop
marriages women who are married to cops
and a lot of times it's because of you
know the the [ __ ] that the baggage that
they carry from their job you know the
[ __ ] that they're seeing on a day-to-day
basis and uh it kind of like creates a
violent tendency in them oh I could see
it yeah Doug there's somebody that I
know he's not a I mean I met him a
couple of times he's not a friend of
mine but just hearing this guy talking
I'm like this [ __ ] needs therapy
here right and he's a cop right for exam
well let me just tell you this quick
[ __ ] story he's so like out of touch
and out of bass with this [ __ ] world
he says the most off-colored [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've ever seen him like we're all
chillin right we're all hanging out
I know homies house this [ __ ]
he's trying to bring in something to
talk about because we're all having fun
we're making jokes yeah and this guy he
wants to be you know in the social
circle and tell stories as well so this
fool just comes out out of the nowhere I
should you know he goes like this he
goes have you ever seen a brain
splattered on the wall for somebody
trying to kill themselves the room goes
dead radio silent yeah it's [ __ ]
crazy and I just look at him I go what
the [ __ ] and I start busting up laughing
right and I'm laughing not because the
story is funny it's just like you're
socially um yeah yeah why the [ __ ] would
you say that he goes dude this smell is
terrible yeah yeah when you walk in
there I just it makes me want to gag and
throw up I saw this person who committed
suicide and I just had a look at that
room is silent and I'm just like what is
wrong with you way to go debbie downer
yeah [ __ ] a cop you socially [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] you know what I mean
like this guy's a little off man and
you're hearing this guy speak enough
sometimes I just want him to be around
so I could see so I could hear the next
dumb [ __ ] he's gonna say yeah and like
you're supposed to protect and serve
this is just a little socially oh no
he's so aggressive - he's so angry all
the time when he's that guy where
they're so whatever they've seen on the
streets whatever they've been through in
the last like whatever ten years he's
been a cop has [ __ ] with him mentally
yeah and he needs help
well I mean look some of those guys are
on that power trip you know me I'm not
trying to generalize like what some of
their pasts might have been like but
look I don't think it's it's a
far-fetched thing to say that some of
these guys were probably bullies before
you know and they became a cop now very
early with a badge yeah you know and so
again there there's a it's the bad seats
within the hole right it's not it's not
all cops are [ __ ] racist [ __ ] of
course not you know yeah yeah for sure
me too I mean I didn't feel that way
when I was younger when I was younger it
was [ __ ] the police all the time you
know but uh as I became an adult and
started having a you know a little bit
more maturity behind my thoughts yeah I
mean I've met cops that were really cool
and I've met cops who were [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know and and and no reason other
than to just be an [ __ ] because they
can right and so like for me I haven't
been on the end of having police
violence done to me right but I've
definitely had cops abusing their power
you know and I don't know if it has
anything to do with like me being a
minority because those cops who did kind
of flex their their power in abusive
ways I would say were white cops right
yeah I don't know if it's that dynamic
where it's like oh yeah you know you're
just a piece of [ __ ] minority you know
and and I'm gonna basically treat you
and talk to you however I feel like
right I don't know I don't know if it's
that or if they if if they were just
profiling you know like look at the way
this kid dresses look at look at his
friends right look at what he's wearing
you know this kid is is fits the profile
and I feel like - they've been trained
that way - it's like this is the profile
most likely they're gonna be doing some
[ __ ] no I just I just can't it's hard
man like I I wish I can get a cop on
your that would speak openly because I
know like a couple of homies were cops
but they don't want to come on here and
do this yeah there's a lot of pressure
it is I mean I feel like maybe at best
like an ex-cop who's who's like I know
one ex-cop but he doesn't want to like
he actually left the force because of
that type of corruption the racial
profiling and he just didn't feel right
and yeah oh he left and you know you
want to talk about it so you know I've
tried a few avenues and they don't feel
comfortable so I understand but I want
an active cop to come in here not to
offend themselves but just to give the
public view of like hey this is this is
the stuff that we see this is how we're
taught how to deal with the stuff and
this is the reason why it happens this
way or maybe there's like some
acknowledgment that there was something
that was wrong here yeah but I guess
because what people want is you know if
these are your people
this isn't in police your own people but
we can't do it that a civilian can stop
a cop and be like hey you're not
supposed to do this because you saw what
happened with that young with with Floyd
who apparently is like Steven Jackson's
like really close friend he looks like
Steven Jackson they're actually really
close friends oh really
they're like highschool friends I didn't
know that and so they were like they
used to call each other twins uh-huh so
back in the day yeah and so like Steven
Jackson when he would come in town he
will hook him up with a bunch of like
like gear and [ __ ] like that and yeah
Steven Jackson put something out that I
wasn't homey [ __ ] he looks just like
when I saw the face I was like that's
Steven Jackson yeah now that you mention
it I do see the similarity yeah they're
like [ __ ] twins man yeah but I don't
know man like the [ __ ] that's going on I
mean that's just adding to like what a
shitty year 2020 has been so far I know
man it's just insult to injury right and
so it's like I just read a like memes
getting created about the situation as
like about the the rioters and the
looters is like oh you know I forgot
about kovat real quick right it's like
no man they didn't [ __ ] forget about
kovat real quick yeah it's just this
situation is bigger than that you know
it's it it's like it's it's too raw yeah
it's like drawing such a raw [ __ ]
emotion you know and look I I wish it
didn't have to get to that mm-hmm but it
did you know and it's like what sucks
about that situation is now the
narrative is gonna switch to the to the
rioters and the looters you have what a
piece of [ __ ] they are yeah you know
like yeah look at these groups of people
you know because you know it's gonna
fall back on the mind
oops again yeah right they're gonna be
like that is why you know these things
happen because they don't know how to
they don't know how to act or they don't
know how it's a lose-lose situation
exactly like because in me like I
understand sometimes it's like okay I
did it the way that you asked you're
still [ __ ] with me yeah well if I'm
gonna be treated like [ __ ] I might as
well just sock you up anyways and at
least I'll get something out of this
yeah you know and that's what probably
what it feels like yeah it's like okay
you put out these dumb tik-tok videos am
I being detained
uh how to deal with cops right and this
is white guy and this white girl is like
his daughter or his girlfriend he was
like this is how you do it
am I being detained am I free to go and
she walks away [ __ ] that
happened you white [ __ ] that's why I
you [ __ ] unsocial II aware [ __ ] not to
mention I feel like I don't know what I
mean this is pure speculation I have
nothing to back it up but it's just a
thought that I have is that when a white
person is is recording I feel like it
presents a different kind of threat yeah
to the cop of oh I better be a little
bit more responsible here yeah you know
versus a minority doing it yeah I feel
like a minority doing it escalate the
situation and a white person doing it
will kind of keep the situation at bay
you know and again it's just pure
speculation but from some of those
videos that I've seen that's kind of
like the vibe that I get from the
demeanor of the police officer one of
the worst videos I saw was this guy I
don't remember he was like light-skinned
of black doing he was Mexican or some
[ __ ] but he was being pulled over and
for some some random [ __ ] and he was
asking why he's being tailed what's
going on ball on blah and this female
cop got mad aggressive it was like a he
was being pulled over and then she pulls
a gun on him he recorded everything and
he's like yo whoa what's going on it's
like you're pulling a gun on me she goes
you need to get outside the car right
now
I think she'll a lot sir job and
everything else huh isn't that so
[ __ ] scary it's like a routine stop
and then the cop pulls a gun on him it's
hypothetical that escalated quickly
it's [ __ ] great and I've seen like
some [ __ ] up cause they get mad
aggressive they say some pretty like
racist [ __ ] yeah you know and I'm
talking about me I was called he didn't
call me a [ __ ] but you know my guy
basically said like oh you don't speak
English you know basically you know
doing like a little Chinese Lily I'm
like that's [ __ ] tear this is like
when I was like 16 I'm like in terrible
oh boy I was like dude man you're a cop
dude yeah I wish one of my homies we
just [ __ ] you right now dude I'm a [ __ ]
yeah wish yeah I mean yeah the [ __ ] is
wrong with this guy you know I'm a nerd
- it's like what the [ __ ] why don't he
write you know again police police
police yeah I mean once a bully and it I
would argue that they become even bigger
bully because now they have got some
power yeah they have the right to be a
bully now you know yeah not only not
only that they have their whole force to
back them up yeah and they're not just a
lone ranger like a rogue agent right
they know like they got they got they
have their back and they really can't do
no wrong
you know everything they do is just a
fight just following protocol I'm just
doing my job you know they were posing a
threat I had to put him down right as
the same story time and time again and
it's just like you can't you can't keep
spoon feeding people [ __ ] you know
like people catch on yeah and and look
before maybe because there was a shroud
of mystery it was easier to kind of like
give the benefit of the doubt but in
this age of technology there's nowhere
to [ __ ] hide you know from start to
finish
right it's pretty [ __ ] clear and it
makes you think right that if when when
people see these types of footages right
and there's such an overwhelming
response to that and a reaction to that
yeah right
don't you think that there's something
wrong there right not not a not paying
attention to like what's the minority
group of people of you
would say oh yeah that was just a fight
or again what did they do or look this
person had had a rap sheet your or you
know had misdemeanors and so it was
justified that's that's a smaller group
of people most of the people whose
reactions who have reactions to that are
one of anger you know of one of sorrow
you know one of it basically is it shows
compassion you know and so what does
that tell you right now that there's
something systemically wrong you know
and look man I don't have the answers to
that you know I mean people can throw
around ideas all day of what needs to
change right but until the people in
power actually do something about it
it's really falling on deaf ears right
and it that's the saddest thing about it
is that this [ __ ] has been going on for
so long and honestly the situation
hasn't improved I don't even think in
the slightest Yeah right sure still
doesn't feel like it no I mean I mean
like I guess post segregation right it
hasn't changed
yeah you know and and you have
politicians man some politicians who
let's say aren't aren't exactly the most
diverse group of people yeah that's just
to be real man yeah I mean it's yeah I
mean I mean that's really just all I
have to say about it there's I mean I
could I could probably go on for days
about this but it's um you know if
you're out there and you feel like I'm
not I'm not on the side of saying people
who are silent like you guys are just as
bad I don't think so I think sometimes
like if you don't know what to say it's
better that you just stay quiet right
and then if you can if you do feel
compelled to just you know share a post
share a story and speak about the
injustice in any kind of small way
possible
you are helping in a certain way and if
you don't do it because you feel
uncomfortable I'm okay with that too
because not everybody is the same right
now some people just
have that big voice they don't have that
ability to speak for that stuff yeah and
then when you get mad at people who
don't do it the way that you do it you
shouldn't be because they're not you
right right and also to some people who
just didn't grow up around the stuff
they didn't grow up around they don't
know about the stuff that's going on so
they're not as passionate I mentioned
this before earlier it's like the reason
why I feel like I'm passionate about
this because I partake in the culture so
I feel like I should give back so well
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast I hope we kind of you know
thought through our thoughts when we
spoke on this write in the comments
below about what you think if you're
watching this on youtube or any other
platforms and then you know you can
catch edrick at IDI
too on on instagram and you could check
out our clothing line a secret society s
RTS o CI et Y and then yeah yeah hit me
up if you guys have any thoughts or
ideas about this topic you know I'm
always interested to kind of get like a
more perspective on what people are
thinking and how people are feeling but
yeah it's just you know treat it like a
living room conversation then we just
had about it and it's obviously a really
sensitive subject matter right now and
and the emotions are very raw for a lot
of people but I think the most important
thing is that we start with a
conversation yeah you know an honest
conversation yeah and at least have that
be the catalyst hopefully something
bigger and better you know yeah cool
well guys we'll catch you next time
have a lovely [ __ ] day and I hope you
get a lot of penis and vagina